[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 181 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" podcast.
I am Mark, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hi, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, are you Mark
Mandel or Mark Mirchianiani?
[BUZZER]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Mirchandani.
That's a good way to
stumble through the fact
that you don't know how
to pronounce-- you know,
I feel like I've done a lot of
last name jokes here, though.
But so I'm not going
to hold it against you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you should.
You should.
You should give me grief
for that for a long time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It's a long last name.
So Mark Mandyel, right?
[BUZZER]
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
That would--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: With the
y's in it and everything?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
That sounds good.
Excellent.
Who do we have
joining us this week?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So this week--
MARK MANDEL: As I
change the topic.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
So this week-- and I hope I
pronounce her name correctly--
but it should be Angela Yu.
[DING]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I believe so.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Who we chatted
with about the Google Maps
platform, which I
think a lot of people
are familiar with
Maps in general.
But in this case, we're
talking a little bit more
about some of the recent updates
that have been done there
and how you can actually build
some really, really cool ideas
with Maps, right?
Like it's more than just an API.
It's actually a
new way to approach
thinking about building
your app, or your website,
or whatever it is.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
being able to use
that local data and any
information that they
have in Google Maps within
your own application
is pretty awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
But before we get
to that, we've also got to talk
about our question of the week,
which in this time will be a
little bit about Kubernetes
and what is Helm, the package
manager for Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: So, yeah.
I think, Mark, you
were just like, I
don't know what this is, Mark.
Can you tell me?
So I was like, all right, cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I feel, yeah,
I've talked about it before.
And I've understood
it at a high level.
But then it kind of came up.
And we'll talk a little
more about this later.
But it's like, what
is Helm, and why Helm?
MARK MANDEL: Why is it a thing?
Cool.
But yes, before we
get into all of that,
we do have our cool
things of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Looks like I'm going
first this week.
Haha, excellent.
So this week, we got
several cool things.
I'm particularly
excited by this.
We have announced
that Google has
entered in to a definitive
agreement to acquire Looker.
It's a unified platform
for business intelligence,
data applications, and
embedded analytics.
Basically, they make
really pretty graphs that
are really easy to understand.
It's really nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Which
a lot of people highly
desire because I forget
who was saying it earlier.
But they were basically
saying, there's
a lot of solutions out there
for doing the actual analytics,
the calculations.
And that's all fine and dandy,
but at the end of the day,
someone's got to look at those
and make decisions based off
of it.
And you can't do that
without basically
being able to visualize
it or summarize it
in a meaningful way.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I'm very
excited about this upcoming
acquisition, so keep you
updated on how it all goes.
But yeah, it's going to be neat.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I think
it'd be really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Speaking of new tools
that people can get their
hands on here at Google,
we've just kind
of launched out--
I saw a blog post earlier
about the version 3
of the Translation API--
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--that a lot of people
are familiar with, right?
You send it some text.
You kind of send it
some information,
and it translates it.
Well, now with the
new version, it's
actually super cool
because you can kind of
create your own glossaries.
So that's really
helpful for business--
MARK MANDEL: Fancy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--specific logic
and any terms that are tied
into what you're trying to do.
And you can actually specify
which model you want to use.
So whether it's
Google's built-in models
or if you want to
provide custom ones,
they're making it
easier and easier
to train your own models, like
AutoML, those kind of things.
It's super awesome to kind
of bring more customization.
I think a lot of people have
always wanted translation.
And it's always
been a little tricky
because you have like
deep, technical talks.
And everyone's kind of
mentioned all these products
and translations.
Like, I don't know
what those are.
Well, now you can kind
specify those and really get
some really cool results.
MARK MANDEL: That would be cool.
I can see a lot of
uses cases for that--
games, but.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Not that
we make up a lot of words,
when you have to go
fight the space alien.
I want to throw in brand names
here because I know them.
But I don't want to
get in trouble for it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
But there's anywhere that
you have a custom vocabulary
I think is always useful.
[ALIEN SPEECH]
Well, in last week's episode,
we talked about a Google Cloud
networking in depth article.
This week, there's
a whole new one.
It's Google Cloud networking
in depth Cloud CDN.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh.
MARK MANDEL: So if you
wanted to see basically
how Google Cloud uses its
points of presence and its edge
locations to be able
to cache and load
balance your
information at the edge,
so that people can get
faster access to it.
And also how you can use
the cloud CDN product
and what features
it has, so that you
can take advantage of
that as well explicitly
within your applications.
This is actually a really
good little article.
So it gives you some
background and also tells you
a little bit about how you
can use the thing using
Google Cloud's
HTTPS load balancer
and how to configure
it, and sort of patents
that you can use
as well for that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I mean,
it's just a great place,
especially to start
understanding,
like if you're going to
throw up something as simple
as a website or if you want
to do something much more
advanced, like huge asset repos.
Understanding a little bit
more about CDNs is great.
And I think there'll
be more articles
in that same vein about
deep dives for networking.
MARK MANDEL: Well, at least if
we've said so in the podcast,
they have to do it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I mean,
now they're obligated.
MARK MANDEL: Now
they're obligated.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Once this goes live.
MARK MANDEL: That's it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We might
get in trouble for that.
Speaking of last
week, actually, we
were also talking about ways
to save money on Google Cloud.
And one that just
kind of came up
again is very similar to
the talk we had last week.
So if you haven't seen that,
go back and check it out.
It's really cool.
YouTube talked about
how to save money.
In this case, there's a
really, really quick write
up on how to turn on and
off compute instances
with functions.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So maybe if
Kubernetes is too complicated
for you, like it is for me, then
it might make a lot of sense
to do something a lot simpler,
depending on your workload.
Where you can basically just
say Cloud Scheduler, which
is basically managed
cron, and you just say,
OK, well, at 9 o'clock,
turn my machine on.
And at 5 o'clock, turn it off.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Super simple,
maybe four lines of code.
I mean, it just basically has
Cloud Scheduler calling Cloud
Functions, and that's about it.
Super great to have,
and the blog post kind
of checks out the details there.
So definitely a cool,
cool simple way.
MARK MANDEL: Nice,
especially if there's just
something you want to run
once a day, for example.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
definitely extensible, too,
right?
Because the business
logic might say
start it up early,
whatever it is.
MARK MANDEL: Also
some neat stuff.
Finally, I just wanted
to make mention--
unfortunately, last
Sunday, we had an outage.
There is an article
that we have posted up
on the Google Cloud blog
talking about the outage
and incident that
occurred, including
an apology from our
team as well on that.
It has some details of what
happened around networking
and network capacity.
I will defer to the
blog post for specifics.
There is a post-mortem
that has been said
that we will be going through.
And we will be looking
into it further.
But for those people who were
affected, we deeply apologize.
And we will be working
on that further
to make sure it
never happens again.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Always a good
thing to kind of read up on
and kind of understand
this is the real world.
Things are hard.
Problems happen.
And so our team, obviously, is
going to learn a lot from it.
And hopefully, people out there
can kind of read the details
and see why it happened.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, enough
cool things of the week.
I think we've gone
through a lot there.
Let's get right into
our interview, right?
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this week, very happy
to have Angela Yu here
on the podcast joining
us, a developer
advocate for Google
Maps Platform.
How're you doing, Angela?
ANGELA YU: Hi, I'm well.
Thank you for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so
much for joining us today.
Joining both Mark and Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, don't worry.
Mark's here.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, you're here, too.
It's OK.
To talk to us all about Google
Maps and the Google Maps
Platform.
So before we get
stuck in, do you
want to tell us a
little about yourself
and what you do here at Google?
ANGELA YU: Yeah, absolutely.
I'm a developer advocate.
I think we've had developer
advocates on the podcast
before.
MARK MANDEL: A couple.
ANGELA YU: But really,
what that means
for me is I care a lot about
how the developers experience
our APIs.
And as I'm out there
talking with developers
and learning how
they use our APIs,
I bring that back to
the product teams.
And I tell the teams what
is important to developers,
so that we can improve our APIs.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So that makes sense.
But let's take just a high level
step back here, just in case.
Tell us what Google Maps is.
ANGELA YU: I feel like
that Virgin America
video, the safety
videos, like for the 0.1%
that haven't used Google Maps.
Google Maps is really your
window into the real world.
We have made a lot of
investment in collecting
all the data of what exists
in our physical world
all over the planet.
We've tried to be as
complete as possible,
covering the oceans
and the land masses.
And we invest a lot in
keeping that data fresh.
So we're doing like 25 million
updates to our data a day.
And that's updating what
business is at what location
or what's changed in
the roads, or there's
been some flooding-- all of that
from just very tabular textual
data about listings, but
also visual data imagery.
We've seen that we have
satellite imagery for overhead.
We have aerial imagery for
more of the low altitude,
like 45 degree
angles of buildings.
And we have Street View.
You've seen the famous Street
View cars driving around
on the streets capturing,
really, at that address level
and at that building level,
what you see on the streets.
And something I didn't know
before I joined Google Maps was
not only are there
Street View vehicles,
but there are Street View
backpacks for hikers to take.
You can see this site called
Street View Treks that you
can see really amazing views
of the world of areas that
are really hard to get to, like
the front face in Yosemite of--
what's that big rock?
MARK MANDEL: There's a big rock?
I don't know.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's
a lot of big rocks.
MARK MANDEL: There are.
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
Yeah, like that,
and the Himalayas.
And basically, you
can take a backpack.
You can take a tricycle.
We've--
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Is it El Capitan?
ANGELA YU: El Capitan.
[DING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There we go.
I just looked it up.
MAN: Soaring over
3,590 feet, El Capitan
is bucket list destination
overlooking Yosemite National
Park.
ANGELA YU: Clearly,
I'm not a hiker.
But we've enabled bringing that
Street View 360 degree imagery
experience out to the most
remote corners of the world
in order to give you any kind
of window you want to see.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Well, as someone who grew up
with a physically bound paper
map that made me drive around--
ANGELA YU: The paper maps, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We had one
called the Melways, because I
lived in Melbourne, Australia.
It's called the Melways.
Thank you so much for
getting rid of that for us.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
I think a lot of people
have used Google Maps,
I mean, hopefully
to kind of replace some of
the older mapping stuff.
We have this live.
I mean, like you
were saying, you're
pulling in a tremendous
amount of data.
But there's also a Google
Maps API for other people
who want to kind of pull
in their own data, right?
ANGELA YU: That's true.
Yes, so the API allows you
to bring all of that data
that we've collected
into your own apps.
Because everybody has their
own view of the world.
It's not just what is out
there and what is public.
But you might care
about where are you
and where are the things
that you care about,
whether that's from
a personal level,
like the people in
your life, or if you
track your personal property,
if it's moving around.
Or if you're a business
and organization,
and you want to track your
physical assets out there
in the world.
MARK MANDEL: So
what sort of things
are people doing with
the Google Maps API?
What are some good examples?
ANGELA YU: The really cool thing
about working on the Google
Maps API is it spans everyone,
from the individual hobbyist
developer to the
largest enterprises.
Because everybody
has some reason
to be interested in location.
Google Maps API is kind
of often the first Google
API that a developer
will use, just
because as we're experimenting,
we're learning new apps,
it's really satisfying
to pull in a map
and have that show
up on your app,
whether it's on
the web or mobile.
And it's one of the
simplest APIs to use.
So in the beginning,
individual developers
can start using
location data just
to show things like
where is my user,
and show you that geolocation.
And then you can
broaden that to if you
are an app that wants to
show the user certain things
around them that
is not generally
what the regular Google
Maps app would show,
which would be a
lot of businesses.
You might want to show them
specific things, like EV
charging stations or things
that are specific to what
the purpose of your app is.
That is really useful to
both tap into our database
and/or maybe you have a
custom database of your own
of where things are
geolocated that you
want to show around the user.
And also for all
different kinds of users,
you can use the information of
what is around the environment
or where things are located
to help users make decisions.
So if you're trying to
decide, have some resources,
and where should I
concentrate those resources--
I want to find out
where are they needed--
you want to be able
to look at a map
to find out where the
most action is in order
to deploy your resources
to that location.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Like a ride
share company, for example.
ANGELA YU: Exactly, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Is this
limited to if I saw it--
I know I've seen Google
Maps embedded on a web page.
Is it limited to
that kind of view,
or could I use the
data in other formats?
How does this end up
being a user experience?
ANGELA YU: Displaying a map is
kind of the most popular way
to use our API.
But we also have a very
rich database of places,
so that includes businesses,
but also just general places,
like parks or
government buildings.
And all of that rich database
is available through the Places
API.
And then there's
also the Routes API
that gives you access to
things like the directions,
whether through driving
or walking or biking,
and transit and roads.
So you are that ride
sharing company,
and you're seeing a geolocation
of one of your drivers,
and they're nebulously
off of a road.
You can snap it to a real
road that they must be on.
And so all of those APIs are
available through the Maps
Platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So there's location.
There's kind of like
how you actually
do routing, and then
moving some things around.
I think we've actually seen
some pretty interesting use
cases recently of
games implementing
this to create kind of an
augmented reality experience
as well.
ANGELA YU: Mhm.
Yeah, real world
gaming is a big trend.
It was really popularized
by "Pokémon GO."
And from that, we have expanded
our API to game developers
to enable real world gaming
where there is a Playable
Locations API, where game
developers can identify where
are good places for people to
have real world interactions
with things in the game.
And last year, there were five
games released using that API.
And there will be a
lot more this year.
But one of the most successful
ones is like "Walking Dead."
So wherever you are, you can
see zombie attacks coming.
And you might have to
collaborate with other players
in order to defeat the zombies.
So these are really
fun things that you
can do to bring that digital
experience and the real world
experience together.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Can we make
sure there's a real zombie API
just in case?
Just in case that does happen.
MARK MANDEL: Just in case.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It'd be nice to have
a map saying, hey, go here.
Don't go here.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You want your zombie API
as part of the Maps API
that tracks all the zombies.
ANGELA YU: Yes.
I will definitely
prioritize that feature.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thank you.
Appreciate that.
Thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: And it sounds like
there's-- so there's a couple
of games that have
been using it.
What other kind
of trends have you
been seeing of people trying
to adopt this and maybe create
some new experiences?
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
We say the problem of showing
a map and dropping a pin on it
has been solved for 10 years.
So we're really looking at what
are the new things that people
are doing with it.
Obviously, mobile
has been bringing
a lot of interesting
use cases to how
people use the Maps Platform.
Because geolocation
around mobile device
is kind of critical
information for anyone
that's moving around.
Beyond that, I come from,
actually, an IoT background,
Internet of Things.
And this is the idea
of connected things.
Not just phones and
computers, but any asset
could be connected
to the internet.
And especially when those things
are out in the physical world,
they all have location.
And it's very
important to whoever
cares to connect to that
thing to know where that is.
So we've seen a lot
of organizations,
both from the enterprise
to consumer realm, be
interested in collecting
data off of these things,
mapping them so that they can
show the status of things out
in the world.
And maybe many
things in one area
are all showing the same
state or are trending one way.
And then they can make better
decisions based on that.
One example that I saw recently
was one of our Google Developer
experts.
These are external
developers that
have used our APIs extensively.
He has built a
prototype of tracking
bike-sharing bikes and
where they're moving around.
And he's feeding it
to a Firebase database
and then pulling that
database information,
displaying it on a Google Map.
And that really
shows the hotspots
of where these bikes
are actually being used.
So then a bike-sharing
company could
use that data and better
deploy where their bikes
should be available.
Because the worst thing is
if they were to put them off
in where they think the
biking locations are,
and nobody actually is
trying to use it from there.
That's a really
interesting project
that he open sourced it.
And it's out there on Hackster.
We can put a link to
it in the show notes.
But I think that's a
really great example
of using IoT data,
displaying it on a map
and being able to make a
lot better decisions based
on that data.
MARK MANDEL: I think you brought
up something interesting there,
too, where you were talking
about Firebase and the Maps
API.
Given that we're the "Google
Cloud Platform" podcast,
are you seeing
interesting interactions
or grouping of technology with
Google Cloud with the Maps API
mishmashing together?
How does that look to you?
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
One of the biggest
trends that we see
is the big data visualization.
And we have a really great
Code Lab that shows you
how to query big
data from the query
and bring that
into a Google Map.
So then any data
that you have that
has a location aspect to it
can then be put on a map.
And you can process
really huge data sets,
and be able to visualize them,
and really communicate and tell
stories about what is
important in that data,
that you just couldn't
really surface before.
One of the really interesting
things in big data,
there's the BigQuery
public data sets.
If you don't have
your own data set,
you can play with
these public data sets
and do really
interesting things,
just to practice
that muscle and see
what you can do in terms of
data visualizations of location
based data.
But there is also an open
source library called deck.gl
that lets you build really
beautiful data visualizations.
They have all these layers that
you can put over a Google Map--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
ANGELA YU: --that
are specialized
for different kinds of data.
If you had the roots of--
one of the public data
sets is the New York City
taxi and limousine services.
And all of the trips that
the taxis have been taking,
you can use their trips layer
to actually draw on a map
the kind of like time
lapse view of the trips
that all of these taxis were
taking in the time period.
It just works really
well, and it handles
huge data sets really well.
So that's one of the things
that we announced at I/O,
was integration with
deck.gl that we're
really excited for
our developers to try.
MARK MANDEL: Neat.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool.
Were there any other kind of
cool announcements from I/O?
ANGELA YU: From the
Maps Platform side,
we have a new SDK for Android
that we've put out for beta.
And so we're really looking
for developers to try it out,
give us feedback before
we release the GA version.
MARK MANDEL: What makes this
particular version for Android
particularly special?
ANGELA YU: We have actually
brought it out standalone
from the Google mobile
core, so that we
can release more frequently.
Basically, that takes us
out of their release cycle
and puts us on a more
frequent release cycle.
And there are a lot of rendering
improvements for performance.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So with
all those kind of use cases
you were just talking about
and how a lot of people
can get their hands
it, what would you
say is the coolest
experience you've seen
built with Google Maps, right?
The visualization
sounds pretty awesome.
But think about
what's the next step.
MARK MANDEL: I mean,
we had zombies.
What's better than zombies?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I don't
know if we can top zombies.
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
I think there are a lot
of really complex things
that are coming up in the world.
And now it's possible to process
these really complex decisions.
So I'm really
excited to see what's
possible with-- ridesharing
companies are really doing
very complex routing with us.
Because they not only have to
go from point A to point B,
but consider all these
other stops in between
and optimizations.
And what I am most passionate
about is augmented reality
and seeing that go
beyond just the gaming
applications about
augmented reality,
but also how we see the data on
the world around us overlaid.
So one of the big things in
the Android Google Maps app
is the augmented reality
walking directions,
which really helps
people navigate,
especially in big
cities, when they're
trying to orient themselves.
And augmented reality
arrows that kind of
show you exactly where to
walk, those are very helpful.
And I see a lot of more
applications coming out
for making those kinds of
experiences, of showing you
what you're looking
for actually overlaid
on your physical world.
If you wanted to know kind of
the weird stuff that we see,
really whimsical things.
And one of the most
whimsical things that kind of
stood the test of
time is this idea
of making an earth sandwich.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What
is an earth sandwich?
Besides delicious, I'm sure.
ANGELA YU: So it's kind of like
the idea that every kid has of,
if I dig a tunnel all the way
to the other side of the world,
where will I end up?
MARK MANDEL: Burnt alive.
[SIZZLING]
ANGELA YU: That idea of you
being on one side of the world
and what is on the other side
of this sphere, this globe--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
Got it.
ANGELA YU: Those two points on
the globe are called antipodes.
And there are map tools
that let you find antipodes
of from where you are.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
ANGELA YU: And most of
the landmass, actually,
the antipode is in the water.
So there is actually
only, I think,
4% the world that you could
have a land-to-land sandwich.
And so these maps were created
to help people find antipodes--
New Zealand has an
antipode in Spain--
for people to partner up
and try to synchronize, so
that they can put a piece
of bread on one side,
and a piece of bread
on the other side.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, and that's
where the sandwich comes in.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that's fantastic.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, that's brilliant.
ANGELA YU: Yeah,
and so there are
videos where people
document themselves putting
a piece of bread on
this specific latitude
and longitude and their partner
doing it on the other side.
And they have successfully
created an earth sandwich.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh,
which probably would be--
there's going to be a lot of
disappointed six-year-olds out
there that hear that they
can't-- they'll probably end up
with water, though.
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Some galactic
entity is just like, mm, good.
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
Actually, with students, one
of the most popular tools
in the classroom is this
website called The True Size.
Because if you are
a math nerd, you
know that the maps
we're used to seeing
are very distorted to how
the countries actually
lay out on the globe surface.
And so we are so used to
seeing these flat maps
that our ideas of
the size of countries
gets really distorted.
And there's this
interactive web page
called The True
Size, where you can
drag a country to the equator or
overlay it on any other country
to compare their sizes and see
how actually large or small
they are.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What was your biggest
surprise when you tried this?
ANGELA YU: One of
my big surprises
was I didn't realize
that Mexico is actually
as tall as the contiguous US.
And Canada and Russia
look really huge.
But actually, when you bring
them down to the equator,
they're much smaller.
I think Russia is still
really big compared
to other countries, but
it's not as humongous
as it looks on the flat map.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, there was an update.
I don't remember when it was.
But there was an update to
Google Maps, the interface,
where if you zoom
out far enough,
it's switched from that kind
of standard Mercator projection
into the globe one, right?
ANGELA YU: Mhm, yeah.
That is just like it just
switches to that satellite
view.
And it just goes to that
really true representation
of the world.
It's funny that you mentioned
Mercator projection.
Because there's an xkcd
comic that actually
types you based on your
favorite map projection.
And if Mercator
is your favorite,
then you're kind of
just like a lemming
that goes along with whatever's
fed to you in the world.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, I was going
to say I love the Mercator
projection for its nice, flat,
and even distribution.
But I guess I'm not--
I'm just wrong.
MARK MANDEL: I'm impressed you
know what the word Mercator is
because I have no idea.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I took a
geology class 15 years ago.
I know things.
ANGELA YU: You've
paid attention.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, actually,
interesting question then.
So we were having an
initial conversation
before we started about
all the different latitude
and longitude standards or
how you track maps and stuff.
If I'm using the
Maps API, do I need
to go take a geology
class or something?
Like do I need to know
geography or whatever
it is that I need to be doing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
do not recommend it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
do I need to do that?
Or does it make it simpler?
Or how does that work?
ANGELA YU: I think
we've tried to make
it as simple as possible.
The latitude and
longitude, I think
you might be used to
seeing it expressed
in minutes and seconds
in this sexagesimal--
[GUITAR CHORDS]
--way.
But when you actually use
Google Maps on your computer
or on your phone, you'll
see latitude and longitude
expressed in a decimal way.
So it's still going to be
the same first two or three
numbers, like 122 degrees West.
And then instead of having
to convert in your mind
to minutes and seconds,
it's actually just decimal.
MARK MANDEL: I just do
that conversion in my mind
all the time.
It's just what I do for fun.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The formula's
written on the back your hand.
It's fine.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
no, it's in my head.
Yeah.
No, that makes sense.
And then, too, if I'm like,
all this sounds awesome,
and I want to get
started, where do I begin?
Where should I go?
ANGELA YU: One of
the things that I've
been really happy about
since I've started
is every time I talk to
an external developer,
they tell me the
documentation is great.
So I'd start with
our documentation.
We have a ton of
tutorials on there.
We have from the
most simple just show
a map to actually call a
complex distance matrix
to figure out all of
the different times
and distances of multiple routes
to get from point A to point B.
And all of that is
provided in tutorials.
We have code samples.
We have Code Labs to teach you
some of the most common tasks.
And all of that is out there.
On GitHub, we have a
Google Maps organization
that has a bunch of repos for
client libraries and utility
libraries.
So on the regular
Maps Platform, we
have the JavaScript API,
Android SDK, and iOS SDK.
And we have a
bunch of REST APIs.
But in our GitHub
organization, we
have client libraries for
Java, for Node, and Go, Python,
and kind of almost anything that
you might want to program in.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And so the
process for someone to get
started, just like
any other API,
they can just go to the GCP
console, enable the Maps API,
get the key, and then start with
any of those tutorials, right?
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
And one of the great
things about us
is that we, on top of any
credits that you've already
gotten through Google
Cloud Platform,
you also get a
$200 monthly credit
recurring for the Maps APIs.
So your first $200 of Maps
API spend is free every month.
And so that covers any kind of
experimentation or development
that you want to do,
to just try things out
before you actually
go into production
and get a lot of users.
So with that, we try
to encourage and enable
more of that experimentation
and playing around
before it starts to
cost you anything.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds great.
And it sounds like
so that's being
charged as a separate product.
Is that billing
unified with the cloud?
Do I need to set up a separate
account or anything like that?
ANGELA YU: No.
It's all built into your
Google Cloud account.
For any project that
you set up, you just
want to go into the API
libraries or marketplace
and enable the Maps APIs
that you want to use.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
is there anything else
that a developer would need
to know to get started?
ANGELA YU: It's really
self-explanatory.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's
a good claim to make.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
ANGELA YU: Yeah.
We have a really great
technical writing team.
We invest a lot in keeping
our documentation up to date.
And I personally
am really invested
in keeping our samples updated.
And all of our libraries
and samples on GitHub
are open source, so
we really encourage
the community to submit
pull requests, open issues,
let us know if things
are not working for them.
Or if they have ideas for
ways that our libraries could
perform better, have at it.
MARK MANDEL: What's a demo
you wish someone would build?
ANGELA YU: Hm.
One of my pet projects is
with augmented reality,
showing names and ratings
on buildings overlaid right
around you.
Because whenever I travel
to a foreign country,
and it might be harder
for me to understand
or it's a very
dense place, it can
be really hard to match up
an address to a building that
has no numbers on it.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
ANGELA YU: So having that kind
of translation and overlay
to help me kind of
figure out where to eat
or where is this place
that I was told to go
to that I can't figure out.
I think that's kind of
like my next big use case
that I'd really love to see.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So you're standing on
a street, and you're
like, that place is 3 stars.
That place is 5 stars.
That is where I'll eat.
ANGELA YU: Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It sounds
like we're not far, right?
I mean, you were just mentioning
earlier the AR and kind
of the things that people
have built with it.
The I/O app for people
who went to I/O,
you actually had
augmented reality
to tell you where the stages
were and those kind of things.
So hopefully, someone who hears
this is like, I can do this,
and just builds that kind of
restaurant finder or place
finder.
ANGELA YU: Yeah, especially
if you're using Android,
combining our Maps
API with AR Core,
that could be really powerful.
And yeah, just
anything where data
is overlaid on the physical
world around you, I love that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, before we finish
up here, is there
anything that we haven't
managed to mention,
or anything you want
make sure you plug,
or anything you just want
the audience to know about
before we wrap up?
ANGELA YU: Our developer
advocate team, we're
always looking for events
where we should be at.
So I am wangela on Twitter.
So if you have an event that
you want us to go and talk
about Google Maps
or what you can do,
we'd be happy to present at
your event, meetup, conference,
anything.
So just hit me up on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Are you going to be anywhere in
particular in the near future
you want people to know about?
ANGELA YU: We're still planning
out the rest of the year.
So I think the usual
suspects, like the Chrome Dev
Summit, things like that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Wait,
we're here in San Francisco.
Where's the earth sandwich
side of San Francisco?
ANGELA YU: Unfortunately,
I think it's in the water.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, it's
going to be a soggy sandwich.
ANGELA YU: It would be.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's an open sandwich.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, open face.
ANGELA YU: Mm.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That seems cheap.
You could just put
bread on anything
and call it an
open face sandwich.
MARK MANDEL: I'm just
saying it's a thing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's true.
You can't argue that.
ANGELA YU: We're
generous with terms here.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Angela, thank you
so much for joining
us on the podcast
today and telling
us all about Maps.
ANGELA YU: Thank
you, Mark and Mark.
It was good to be here.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks, Angela.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
Thanks to you, Angela,
for joining us this week
on the podcast to talk
about Google Maps.
Really interesting topic hearing
about real world locations
and how people can incorporate
those in our applications
and their games, of course.
So yeah, thanks so
much for joining us.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
other creative ideas
like a sandwich
around the Earth.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
and sandwiches.
Sandwiches are great.
I do like a good sandwich.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's just--
I think everyone can--
maybe not everyone
can relate to maps,
but everyone can
relate to sandwiches.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Now I believe you have
a question of the week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Speaking not of sandwiches,
but instead back to Kubernetes,
so we're recently coming
off of Kubernetes'
five year anniversary--
holiday of creating.
They've been around
for five years.
MARK MANDEL: It's a good time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: They've
been doing some good stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It turns
out it's pretty popular.
MARK MANDEL: A little bit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
if you get a chance,
check out the Kubernetes Twitter
and the Kubernetes Podcast
Twitter, which have
a lot of cool content
over the past few weeks
about the fifth anniversary.
One of the interesting
tweets I saw was,
what's the biggest concern for
Kubernetes that people have?
And it's pretty clear
that the number one
answer is like understanding
how to use Kubernetes.
And as I was
thinking about that,
I said, OK, well, I've done
some work with Kubernetes.
But a lot of people
have talked about Helm,
and I've only
really, really been
at the highest level of Helm.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So what the Helm?
[BOOING]
Like, what is it?
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure that's a
joke no one else has ever made.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It has
to be the first time.
I'll take credit
for it, thank you.
So what is Helm?
Why is that important?
MARK MANDEL: OK, so yes.
So Helm is an open
source project.
It's been around for
quite awhile, actually.
We're going to talk
primarily about Helm 2,
and we'll talk a little
bit about that later.
But it is worth noting, we
do have an episode way back
in the day, episode
50, talking about Helm
with Michelle Noorali
and Matthew Butcher,
talking about Helm in depth.
But at its base level, it's a
package manager for Kubernetes.
OK, so what does that mean?
So the thing I like
to talk about when
I talk about Helm is like if
you've ever used APT on Linux,
or yum, or Homebrew, or anything
like that on a Mac device,
or a Chocolatey on Windows,
basically it's like,
how do I install x thing,
plus all the dependencies
that it has as well?
Because sometimes
things are complicated,
and they have lots of stuff.
And so Helm's really nice
in that first of all,
it has a series
of what they call
stable charts and the chart
is the package, basically.
So if you're like, I want to
install multi cluster Redis,
for example, I can go look
for the Redis Helm chart.
There are some
configurable values
that I can push through there.
And it's going to go and
create all the YAML that
needs to be created to
basically specify, OK,
this is how the Redis
configuration should
see set up.
You've specified that you
want this many nodes in it.
And we can set it all up.
And all the dependencies are
all set up, and it's good to go.
So like, sweet, awesome.
And that works well.
The next level of
that is also, how
do I either delete that, say I
don't want it anymore, and make
sure it cleans everything up?
But also, how do I upgrade it?
So maybe there's a new
version of the chart.
There's a new version
of Redis coming out.
I want to do
something like that.
Now suddenly I can
do a Helm upgrade.
And it'll do all the nice
dependency changes and all
the things I need
to change that way,
so that I can change that
platform as I need to change
it, which is really nice.
The third version of
that is that you might
have an application yourself.
And you might be like, oh,
cool, I have this application.
And it's dependent
on maybe Redis
and maybe several other things.
So I can set up a
chart with sub charts
and have dependencies
set up that way as well.
Maybe there's some configurable
values, that kind of stuff.
So then I can create a chart
specific for my application.
I could even publish
that publicly
if I wanted to as well, so other
people could take advantage.
You can actually have multiple
repositories within Helm,
so if you want a publisher
in charts, you can,
either internally or publicly.
And so it handles that sort
of create, install, upgrade,
delete lifecycle of complex
Kubernetes applications.
It's pretty nice.
I quite like it.
We have one for the
project I work on,
which it works on Agones.
It tracks when did
new versions come up,
what version is kind
of live, what version
is available in the repo--
pretty comprehensive.
I should make note--
Helm 3 is coming up.
So Helm 3 is actually
a full rewrite of Helm.
You can still use Helm 2.
Helm 2 is great, and
stable, and wonderful.
They're getting rid
of some dependencies
inside the Kubernetes
cluster itself.
They have a thing
called Tiller usually
that they used to run in there.
They're actually taking
full advantage of CRDs.
If I don't get
any of this wrong,
you can actually check all
this out on the blog post.
It's going to be a much more
lightweight installation.
It's going to be really nice.
But that's been developed
fully in the open.
You can check it
all out at GitHub.
They were like
writing design docs
before they write any code.
It's actually super, super cool.
But the 3.0.0
alpha-1 is available
if you want to muck
around with it.
But yeah, Helm's really nice.
So just checking
it out, it's worth
having a look at if you
have a complex Kubernetes
application you want to deploy,
and you're looking for a way
to package that up nicely.
Does that answer
your question, Mark?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I think so.
So let me read that back
to you if that's all right.
I mean, basically, you're able
to kind of pull down a chart
if you want to take some kind
of a service, for instance.
Like for instance, you
gave an example of Redis.
And say I want this
in memory database,
so you pull down the chart,
and you kind of deploy it.
And of course, if updates
get rolled out of that,
like a normal package
manager, you can say,
oh, there's updates available.
So I'm going to go grab those.
Helm takes care of all the work
there and helps deploy it out.
But of course, applications are
usually more than one service.
Right?
They might be really complex.
They might have dependencies.
And so you kind of
build all that out.
Plus, you're able to kind of
take your own application,
maybe build it up with a
chart that has sub charts,
and then push that out there,
if, for instance, like Agones,
you kind of have
this complex tree
that you need in order
to deploy the app.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Agones is probably a
good example as well.
I mean, we have a variety of
services, some deployments,
a bunch of RBAC controls
in there as well,
and a whole bunch of CRDs.
Yeah, there's those
and things like that.
And so that becomes super nice.
And Helm does a really nice
job, as well, of templating.
So if you want to
have includes, or you
want to do loops
around stuff, basically
being able to generate that
YAML file sort of on the fly,
there's a lot of
nice tooling in there
that allows you to do that, too.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it sounds
like a super cool concept.
If people are getting
started with Kubernetes,
it might be a great way
to get an application,
or set of services, or
a set of deployments,
or a combination
of all those kind
of up and running
pretty quickly.
And it sounds like people can
go check out the episode 50
in order to see more of
a deep dive about Helm
and the direction they're going.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool.
Yeah, I think that handles it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Cool.
All right, well, before we wrap
up, Mark, what are you up to?
Are you going anywhere cool,
doing any neat content?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So I just came back
from a long road
trip, in which I got
to listen to lots of podcasts.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, good.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So that
was a lot of fun, including
our previous episodes.
It's always fun to
go back and listen
to hear the questions
that we're talking about.
But we do interview
some great people.
So it's actually super cool
to kind of listen on those
and be like, oh,
wow, this is awesome.
And then, yeah, I'm headed
to New York pretty quickly,
actually--
I think maybe even as
early as tomorrow--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, very cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: --to talk to
a couple of customers and chat
with them about
their usage of GCP
for a little show I
do on YouTube called
Stack Chat, where we kind
of interview them about what
their architecture looks like,
some of the decisions that get
made.
So it's super cool to kind of
go into these customer areas,
and talk to them,
and be like, hey,
well, why is this important?
What did you find along the way?
Super, super cool stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
I'll definitely
check out your YouTube channel.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
It's all on the Google Cloud
Platform YouTube channel.
MARK MANDEL: I'll
check that out.
That sounds good.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So what about you?
MARK MANDEL: I think next on
my radar will be Tokyo Next.
That'll be in,
strangely enough, Tokyo.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, it's aptly named.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, aptly named.
We do name things what they
are, generally speaking.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
what does Agones do?
[CANNED LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
not our open source
projects-- very different.
So yeah, Tokyo Next in July.
So yeah, if you're going
to be around Tokyo,
make sure to say hello.
I will be at the inside event,
talking about game stuff.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: As always.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty much.
Fantastic.
Well, Mark, thank you
so much for joining me
on the podcast this week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thank
you for having me, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Always a pleasure.
And thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]